I remember how awkward it was telling
people I was running for president for a
while what they were like president of
you know like your co-op board so I
remember all of these internal hurdles
you have to overcome yeah and then just
saying it to someone and having a
straight face and then have them receive
it in a particular way I'm sure for you
it was a real journey over a number of
weeks and months where you'd say I'm
running to be your congressperson and
then I go over time it would it would
actually become natural and feel like
you yeah I mean I don't know that it
ever really felt a hundred percent
natural but and of course you know you
had your own like stereotypes that you
were overcoming as an asian-american I
had stereotypes that I was overcoming I
had people tell me like the only thing
you should be running for is after your
children like me but you know you sort
of come to a place and a peace with it
and ultimately you know I feel that
decision point for me obviously of
deciding to step off the path that I was
on the CPA path the spreadsheet pad not
that there's nothing wrong with that
that that's a good path I don't want to
step into into public life in that way
and say like I'm planning my flag in the
ground and I'm gonna do what I can to
try to lift my voice to these things
that I think matter that was obviously a
real pivot point in my life and one that
I am you know tremendously proud of
taking in spite of the fact that you
know still today like we were talking
before we came on air like people are
being mean to be on Twitter and I'm
still like oh it's hard come on like how
hard are people's lives out there if
you're not willing to step out get
uncomfortable take that incoming then
what are you actually willing to do